this is how things are now you and me
trapped in this moment endlessly there
has been a lot of talk and a lot of
teasing about dr. strange too but now we
have official confirmation that
development for dr. strange too has
started as it has been confirmed that
scott derrickson the director of the
first Doctor Strange movie will return
to direct sequel Scott did tease a few
months ago about directing the sequel
when he posted this picture to Instagram
with the title not my will but thine be
done see you in September this was
obviously just a tease but now it has
been confirmed that he will come back to
direct a sequel production is supposed
to begin by spring in 2020 with an eye
on a may 2021 release dr. strange played
a huge role in Avengers infinity war and
will no doubt play a huge role in
Avengers in game as well so they want
the sequel to start as soon as possible
without rushing it of course so they can
put it in to face for phase 4 starting
right after Avengers and game with
spider-man far from home the first
Doctor Strange movie ended with a setup
for more dough to become the villain in
the next Doctor Strange films what are
you doing this because I see it long
last was wrong at the world
don't mess all sides however one of the
riders want a nightmare to come in and
be the main villain in the next Doctor
Strange film but as of right now it is
only confirmed that Scott Derrickson
will return to direct the film
the current reports say that they are
still looking for a writer for the next
Doctor Strange film so as far as who the
villain is going to be in the next
Doctor Strange film not much is really
known right now
plus with Avengers endgame coming out
and Doctor Strange playing a huge role
in the movie there's no telling what the
aftermath could be Avengers endgame
could open it up for a new villain
entirely to come in in the Doctor
Strange sequel plus Avengers endgame
we'll have time travel in it so there's
no telling how that will affect the
sequel and not to mention that Doctor
Strange is most likely in Soul world
right now and that could come into
effect for Doctor Strange too as well
but the first step has been taken for
the sequel the director is confirmed the
next step is the writer and the script
based on the timeline for phase 4 Doctor
Strange 2 is going to be a big movie for
Marvel so we can expect more information
on the movie in the upcoming future so
let me know how excited you are for
Doctor Strange 2 and let me know who you
think the villain is going to be let me
know what you think in the comments down
below and I'm also giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet if you
would like to interfere your chance to
win all you have to do subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero and of course don't
forget to subscribe with your
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything related to
Doctor Strange 2 and Avengers endgame as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]